[Musique]
de quoi la radio
j'ai inventé c'est le talk-show
généralistes les gens arrivés et ils
s'agréger autour de la table c'est à
dire qu'au début j'avais un qui renaît
de bien à l'étroit la formule de thierry
était novatrice et et décapante il
mettait un curé un ménisque une [ __ ]
chanteurs autour de la table on dit mon
père vous dites comme vous voulez moi je
dis m'accueillir à m'encourager pas
saisi dans ville c'est à dire où vous
mettez une [ __ ] à côtés d'edouard
balladur ou d'albert de monaco vous
voulez oui non mais j'aimerais bien être
avant oui oui
c'est la première fois de ma ville
qu'est ce que c'est
à partir du moment où tu vas mettre ça
qui rit plus de sexe mais attention
si vous le prenez vous le gardez surtout
au mois d'août qui vous verrez comme
c'était
très chaud ça va me falloir 150 lettres
on peut brûler ça m'a bien
vous l'avenir l'envers mais
ça c'est autre chose pas mal de
sexologues américaine en
le conseil à leurs patientes parce que
ça permettrait son point g et donc je
trouve que c'est assez intéressant d'un
point de féministes
ce que c'est que ce n'était pas ça c'est
pas comme un [ __ ] ma salle
à part ce qui est trop peu de femmes
cette attaque d'éjaculer
je crois que j'en fais trop
c'est le grand maître cécile buffet où
tout le monde bien servir il y avait à
boire et à manger si le cas de le dire
il y avait de quoi se scandaliser de
quoi s'émouvoir y avait une espèce de
deux grandes par tous et télévisuelles
comme ça assez orgiaque on se retrouvait
avec des rencontres absolument
incroyable
type jamel debbouze il fils du général
de gaulle caméra je vous présente jamais
debout
que les toulousains ils remportent tous
les ronds-points généticien et
académicien français oui alors
évidemment je vous faire une interview
proust express est ce que tu crois que
c'est une interview de bernard pivot
mais en fait c'est le questionnaire de
proust simplement je vais vous demander
c'est très important de répondre en
faisant des fautes de français comme
vous et académicien ancian des fautes de
français au beau chant rien n'est plus
facile par exemple si je vous dis vous
fait couper les cheveux tous les combien
vous me répondez je vais au coiffeur une
fois par mois d'accord d'accord encore
une fois le mois on ne couche pas dans
le coup
ronald reagan
[Musique]
bien de près
quel est pour vous le comble de la
misère le compte de la misère oui alors
c'est les fautes et les faux
je je je je je peux aussi bien ouais je
peux aussi bien elle voulait souffler si
vous voulez
et les mois mais je suis sûr vous parlez
très très bien alors le compte de la
misère reçu traité que si
et puis là vous avez envie de boxer ça
va je vois bien tu fais un effort
considérable
alors le compte de la 12 heures le
compte de la misère c'est ça se fait que
bg sa mère non mais ça serait que dc sa
mère d'amy le don de la nature que vous
aimeriez avoir
été pas innocent
de vouloir
avoir sur le même plateau rocco siffredi
et arlette laguiller c'était magnifique
je traduis pour rocco siffredi tablette
ouvrière
on dit beaucoup de choses partie
on dit que c'est un bon fonctionnement
un fonctionnement
série d'émissions je mélange des genres
qu'il aimait me choquait pas pour une
raison simple ce que jésus avait parlé
avec les prostituées le pire exemple de
une [ __ ] archevêque c'est à dire d'un
casting bariolés c'est quand même maître
capello et marine manson j'ai tiré un
animal qui va nous tomber beaucoup de
gens règlent leur téléviseur tout ça est
normal
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout c'est la même chaîne cfoot
n'attrape pas les mouches avec du
vinaigre c'est à dire que pour que les
gens s'intéressent à tombo fois ben watt
* par exemple il faut qu'ils sachent
qu'après il ya un commiqué qu'avant il
ya une bimbo moi ç'a toujours été ma
théorie c'est de spectacularité la
culture jacques bret easton ellis
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et merci ma vie ta gueule
d'amour ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
talmud quoi c'est
américains importants qui a donné envie
de lire à plein de gens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inutile de dire à quel point nous sommes
flattés de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau tom bouge
beaucoup c'est un grand plaisir d'être
ici le lendemain j'appelle ma mère elle
me dis qu'est-ce qu'il est sympathique
que ce tome ouf comme m il là je me dis
[ __ ] tournée mission sert à quelque
chose quoi il met sur le même pied
un chanteur de variétés un guitariste de
rock et michel houellebecq ça vous fait
quoi de pas être reconnu comme le grand
écrivain vous êtes michel houellebecq je
suis pas inquiet sur l'avenir du
l'avenir du jugement sur les livres quoi
c'est pas vrai que c'est un juste un
phénomène commercial sans lendemain ce
livre sera lui longtemps non je suis
rassuré vraiment tout le monde m'a dit
'maintenant l'audience je panique et ont
des missions au début de l'émission 38
minutes avec welbeck et ça a très bien
marché c'est ça dont j'avais envie
d'avoir en même temps elie wiesel sur le
plateau et adriana karembeu alors
l'idéal témoin et survivant de
l'holocauste
défenseur infatigable des droits de
l'homme et votre humanisme vous avez lu
en 1986 le prix nobel de la paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense qu'à l'arrivée ça rendait les
gens intelligents tous et surtout je
trouve que le téléspectateur avait
toujours à picorer des éléments dans
l'émission pour moi c'était vraiment une
émission de service public
tout le monde bien à tout le monde en
parle atcha which will et mariah carey
jane fonda
tous bien jesse cox d'un douanier de
stéphanie qui dit ça ça le fait quand
même
ouais c'est angelina jolie
[Applaudissements]
macheist ig
victoria beckham
kylie minogue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
espoir tout le monde françois
robinet qu'on soit vous êtes plutôt rare
à la télévision je crois que c'est la
première fois que vous participez à un
talk show en france non
un
doublement des infos quoi dîner parce
que c'était l'émission phare
c'était le talk show français dans
lequel il fallait être chez bruce willis
dit je vous préviens j'ai pas tellement
de temps je veux faire une seule
émission de promotion si simple au divin
c'est tout le monde en parle terminé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as fait tu étais en france pourtant
fibre est jeté en france et si le mec tu
lui dis qu'il ya une émission qu'il faut
faire c'est redit son et d'image faire
du son
également choir les fidèles de beaucoup
de gens en france et surtout d'hélène
ségara ici voilà il est la touche et le
hélène touché le voilà là deux idoles
dans sa vie c'est orlando et vous donc
alors c'est vous qui l'avez eue c'est
vous qui avez eu l'idée du nom depeche
mode a
embauché malheureusement oui c'est moi
alors c'est le nom d'un magazine de mode
français pourquoi pas elle car j'étais
écolier à l'époque j'ai étudié en fait
la mode
on avait fait un concert qui concerne
dans un pub à londres et puis nous
n'avons pas encore de nom alors il y
avait ces magazines devant nous l'a été
et puis de sipan demander quel est le
nom du groupe alors c'est le premier
magazine que j'ai pris jeudi derek c'est
peut-être d'eiffarie clair quand même
quand j'étais petit j'ai goûté raid
chars
légers assuré tiens
les gens vivent parmi nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment
qui a été
tellement émouvant tellement
quand il est arrivé sur ce plateau est
est-ce qu'il a dégagé comme positivité
c'est inoubliable c'est la première fois
que l'intervieweur lui de pose une
question sur la mort de son frère jamais
personne n'avait osé lui parler de son
frère voilà la différence des tirs et
des autres alors à l'âge de 5 ans vous
vivez la décharge le premier dame de
votre vie votre frère se noie devant vos
yeux dans un baquet plein d'eau pendant
que votre mère repasse et comme les
vêtements d'autres frères sont gorgés
d'eau vous êtes incapable de le
ressortir du baquet
est ce que c'est ce traumatisme qui a
commencé à vous faire perdre la vue
perdre mon frère c'était une chose peut
être magique c'était tout à fait
différent c'était pas liés
l'amendement des deux frères et bien
j'en ai fait
sentir
j'avais l'impression que je refuse
pourquoi le sauve donc elle a fallu
longtemps pour que je puisse récupérer
et à la fin il est parti
et j'ai mis georgia on my mind pas
manquer repart comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même bernard henri lévy
qui comprend rien la musique des émules
et merci beaucoup pour ce moment que
nous faisons passer je suis bouleversée
de
2,2 tout cela de tout ce qui vient de se
passer
merci bernard moi j'ai toujours voulu
faire l'émission dans mon décor si on
dit par exemple il vous dit adam quitte
à paris il serait ravi qu l'interview
mais il faut aller dans une suite à
l'hôtel bristol je dis fuck
fuck soit il vient chez moi ça je le
fais pas hélas matt damon brad pitt 2010
va presque guy wallemme à bien faire des
missions et ses petits coups je les
attends à ils veulent pas venir dit il
faut qu'on reconstruise le décor au
bristol aujourd'hui je sais pas si une
émission frais cet effort donc je vais
en repérage et c'est extraordinaire le
bristol avait un peu la couleur
enfin la salle que nous mettait à
disposition le bristol était avec
quelques colonnades sauf que catherine
avait un un directeur de production qui
était le fils de sa femme de ménage
c'est pas moi qui t'ai pas vraiment un
vrai directeur de production et le mec a
dit ça va coûter je te combien de gens
retraités ont dix mille euros catherine
est super d'huile et
l'oubli
j'accueille brad pitt
j'y retrouve
matt damon
et john o'shea dunne
[Musique]
alors bonsoir à tous merci de sortir
votre film la semaine de la 200ème le
commandant tard c'est très cool ça nous
fait une bonne promo vous joue surtout
en face d'eux et là évidemment ça c'est
la grande différence avec les américains
c'est à dire que les américains ils
arrivent ils vous il vous donne deux
heures de leur temps il faut le travail
proprement sans mégoter son dire vrai
mais qu'ils aillent en france dix mois
la filiale à problèmes temps là ton
émission là parce que j'ai un rendez
vous là connard je vais parler de ton
film de tapas en minute c'est dingue
quand même les américains ils font le
job et eux pour commencer c'est à dire
qu'ils ont ces marais on a fait des
blagues sur des conneries ce délicieux
se charrient entre eux ils sont chers
c'est un bonheur des pros you want sex
work
on vous rendez fonctionné comme ça
hier soir vous savez que vous pouvez
rester à paris tant que george bush est
président des états unis si vous voulez
on peut vous offrir l'asile politique
ne sont pas marché du tout ça il faut
savoir si ça marche pas ce qui marche
c'est dave tu fais dave tu fait plus
d'audience que avec brad pitt belle
c'est ben beau fils
et formulaire avec des jld c'est que ça
marche toujours oui enfin 10 et encore
on peut passer des succès de julien
clerc plus actuel que les miennes
oui j'ai eu des coups de foudre bah oui
c'est normal hors soient les plus jolies
filles de parer le du monde certaines
fois après la tentation la session et
vous avez dit j'aime repousser mes
limites émotionnel et sexuelle je n'ai
jamais été attaché mais je sens que la
personne à qui je laisserais faire ça
sera la bonne je pense que j'adorerais
ça
c'est vrai oui
l'une des femmes les plus séduisantes
que j'ai reçu sur mon plateau c'est jane
fonda qui à l'époque déjà pas tout jeune
et qui draguait baffie jane fonda
madrague et oui
rien
je suis d'oran florent je suis très
gentils nous avait l'air
intéressant d'ailleurs de regarder une
autre femme faire avoir un orgasme
jamais vu ça
c'est beau mais pour doute à tort non ah
bon auteur conteur et puis à ces
scénarios des choses comme ça
j'ai une petite épicerie à château mais
bon là je démarre
aujourd'hui je passe te rends compte si
ma fille avait été d'accord il repartait
tous les deux ainsi sur 1 mais bon bain
fils a posé un geste m'a mis mal à
l'aise et j'ai pas tout de lui lire
toute l'admiration que j'avais pour elle
[Applaudissements]
et celle ci un trophée je suis très sexy
anggun moitié trop pas sexy et je ne
traiterai ces crédits elle est là la sq
haute et regard du talent à malmö fait
complètement craquer on a compris alors
on continue premier rapport sexuel
premier impôt sexuelle assez tard je
crois que 14 15 ans c'est un oui mais
c'est super ça rassure bien les pères de
thaïlande j'ai une fille quelqu'un
devant une carte 13 ans tu veux d'un
coup ça me way oui parce que j'ai trois
enfants il faut faire c'est à dire tout
de suite mais j'espère
donc effectivement 12 ans les premières
photos rappellent qu'elles 14 modèles
pour des robes de mariée dans une petite
gloire locale des mariés prennent
toujours des jeunes filles très de 14-15
attendait serge c est ce qu est ce que
je peux voir ce qui vient de se passer
ce que je peux avoir un petit replay ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une éducation très libre sans aucun
interdit donc moi j'allais dormir chez
mon copain alexandre qu'il faisait en
bras chez sa chaussette sale cent fois
passeport pour me prouver que je
l'aimais assez bien
non ça
regarde moi je sais que c'est pas mal
ouais ouais j'en ai fait des chansons
ses chaussettes sales oui
moi j'ai un peu pourri ranspach ses
débuts des pieds patrick vaz image
est ce que par amour en cage vous seriez
printemps brasse et 100 fois ses
chaussettes sales question tautil de
kourou
oui
je devais avoir une vingtaine d'années
c'était probablement de mes premières
grosses émissions mais bien évidemment
thierry réservé pour la jeune fille un
peu naïve là le questionnaire le plus
chaud 38% des femmes préfèrent le matin
au réveil et 73% des femmes françaises
préfèrent le soir au coucher moi je
préfère un n'importe quand n'importe
quand même en pleine émission
justement je voulais tant par les
tournées
j'avais l'impression que si on posait
une question j'ai été obligé de répondre
mais nous on n'est pas obligé de
répondre pape et moi je répondais et en
plus au premier degré c'est pour ça que
je veux plus jamais avoir saisi
interview parce que je déteste mes
réponses 39% des femmes c'est beaucoup
refusent la fellation et vous
manifone
[Musique]
l'invention majeur de l'émission est
d'abord d'introduire les politiques à la
télévision qu'ils vont y aller avec un
poignard dans le dos sachant qu'ils vont
se faire crucifier les hommes politiques
sont souvent pris à rebrousse poil ou
sont souvent obligés de parler des
choses qu'ils taisent les plus grands
noms souvent dans leurs discours vous
connaissez cette chanson
[Musique]
ces fonds pourraient parfaitement être
amis je suis pas sûr que la conviviale
mais pourquoi parce qu'elle est dans le
prêt-à-penser les politiques sont des
durs il va essayer de fendre la cuirasse
il va réussir
généralement à fendre la cuirasse et
c'est comme ça que les clés que de
politique bon se faire aimer des
français
si j'étais président jack lang combien y
aurait-il de gay pride par an
vous êtes il y en aurait plus aucune
puisque finalement jorion profondément
transformé l'erreur la visserie mineurs
me guèye fall
il est avéré qu'une stagiaire de
l'elysée a eu une relation sexuelle avec
vous quand on vous voit en comprend vous
réagissez comme en très bien
chez moi ils avaient au moins l'occasion
de montrer leur vrai jour je pense à un
avantage les toc chose c'est que ça
révèle les gens quand c'est bien fait
moi je me souviens de rocard je me
souviens de ma la dure
je me souviens de gorbatchev qui on
faisait faire ça c'était une image qui
m'a beaucoup frappé
à ce moment là c'était assez original
était impressionné par le fait de
gorbatchev est accepté pour tout vous
dire mon dieu là vraiment il prend tous
les risques mais il a pris tous les
risques c'est très bien si j'avais à
refaire la périphérie qu'un
je l'aurais fait le même choix
j'arrive toujours à réjouit la liberté
la démocratie l'ouverture
rocard quand il est arrivé j'ai fini
l'interview déjà de 20 minutes sur sa
carrière michel regard bonsoir bonsoir à
vous êtes l'homme du règlement du
conflit en nouvelle calédonie longue
durée ni de la csg j'ai parlé de la csg
tu dire la mcit et surprise on n'est pas
à samedi dont connaissez bien le dossier
du nom je travaille on reprend le
tournage et on fait l'interview alerte
aux roses que tu le des interviews d'un
puits se faisait habituellement l'époque
michel rocard aa1 pire est à venir c'est
l'interview alerte aux roses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
embrasser s'est trompé
non ah bon qu'est ce que c'est que cette
philosophie que vous voudrez balle et là
je sais pas je me demande ma job et ça
dépend du contexte et j'espère bien que
non ouais euh quand on interroge un
politique il faut aussi du chef répond à
des questions auxquelles n'a pas envie
de répondre et sucer c'est tromper et
pardon sucer c'est tromper non non
je crois que l'entourage de michel
rocard quand même toujours voulu de
l'avoir
dirigé là dessus je traite mes cheveux
comme témoin je le dis d'autant plus que
j'aime bien michel rocard il aurait pu
être un peu plus à la hauteur si j'ose
dire à la fin de l'enregistrement c'est
à niveau à rocard que se connaissaient
bien et je lui dis je suis dit est ce
que vraiment ça te pose un problème est
ce que tu veux que ça intervienne est ce
qu il a réfléchi cinq minutes et il m'a
dit non comme c'est un mec qui avait
divorcé trois fois il venait de se
marier avec une femme qui avait 20 ans
de moins que lui il s'est pas super
choqué c'est un type qui était assez
libre danse et dans ses relations comme
ça ça a choqué personne ça me faisait
marrer tout le monde c'était très
provocateur pour l'époque une semaine
après schneidermann mon grand ennemi
daniel schneidermann du monde qui
commentent ils sont pâles comme ça 1 1
un ex premier ministre c'est
inadmissible et là tout le monde s'en
est rendu compte mais ni au tournage ni
au montage mis à la diff personne
n'avait remarqué et personne ne se
souvient de la réponse de michel rocard
qui est quand même le moment le plus a
lieu savoureux et personne n'a critiqué
car tout le monde a critiqué thierry et
sucer c'est tromper et parfois en sucer
c'est tromper
non plus ils ont ils ternel mange sauvé
celui qui a dit ça comme jacques chancel
et dieu dans tout ça
c'est la phrase voilà est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper c'est comme un herpès
alors je me posais une question vous
avez m'en vouloir
mais j'y suis obligé de vous la poser
parce que quand on a j'ai eu des
conversations téléphoniques avec votre
entourage pour réparer cette émission
ils m'ont dit faut pas lui parler de ça
devait recevoir edouard balladur pendant
qu'une semaine à son attaché de presse
m'appelle en dix ans surtout ne lui
dites pas qu'il est turc l'attaché de
presse de balladur n'aurait jamais dû
dire à tirer sur tout je vous en prie ne
lui posez pas la question sur ses
origines quand je les entends dû lui
dire ça ce monsieur aulas il va y aller
à tous les coups là on lui dit faut pas
le faire c'est un provocateur donc
automatiquement insee on m'a dit il faut
pas parler à edouard balladur de ses
origines turques parce que ça va
l'énerver c'est alors je vois pas non
excusez-moi je me suis je vous sais de
la parole moi je vois pas ce qui vient
d'abord évidemment
de péjoratif à est d'origine turque
surtout que votre famille on peut en
parler d'eux depuis très longtemps lié à
la france puisque vous étiez d une
famille de citoyens ottomans et protégé
français protégés de deux longues de
longue date alors moi je comprends pas
parce que des fois on vous reproche
d'être hautain d'être distant et en fait
vous êtes un travailleur immigré oui si
on veut
[Applaudissements]
moi car il est effectivement scène il ya
quelques générations
et puis voilà quoi c'est tout c'est noël
comme je dois dire ne pas lui en parler
de façon générale je parle très peu de
moi oui bon j'ai pris un risque en
venant chez pour un blu ray interne par
bah on va voir on va voir le lendemain
matin coup de fil de balladur au montage
bonjour c'est de voir balladur écoutez
monsieur dix ans je ne suis pas turc et
d'ailleurs si vous voulez vous venez à
mon bureau immédiatement et je vais vous
prouver je ne suis pas turc j'appelle
michèle cotta ses coutures gros problème
avec balladur il veut pas aller mais il
veut que je coupe ça alors que je vois
pas pourquoi je le couperet quoi et elle
m'a dit tu en fais pas le west sort au
mariage de ces pas qui est ce que je
vais lui expliquer bien mieux ailleurs
ajouté malheureusement il très con quand
même heureusement qu'il n'a pas été
président et puis finalement c'est aussi
la loi du jeu c'est aussi la loi du 10
rue de la loi de l'émission est
naturellement la laisser c'est
finalement une émission où on a trouvé
au contraire que balladur que toujours
un peu coincé faut le dire se décoincer
quand les gens viennent dans une de mes
émissions ils savent à quoi s'en tenir
coi et
effectivement je parle de choses dont il
faut pas parler on va faire une
interview je fous la merde
johnny depp
n'est toujours pas mariés donc
voudrais pas qu'il est un peu moins bon
ce moment
il faut
jamais votre anniversaire
tu te rends compte non plus non mais
faire si longtemps pour savoir s'il est
parfait moi je suis confiant tout de
suite et il est parti c'est jean gol et
parfois quand même
type tempérament de feu ouais et qui
sait pas ce genre très facile
me souviens de jean dujardin avec
alexandra lamy il arrive il s'est échoué
ou louent la grande complicité tout de
suite ouais ouais j'ai skié en parlant
de vous et c'est mon pote avec des seins
c'est sympa ça
voilà oui justement alors j'ai des
problèmes avec vos conjoints respectifs
il paraît qu'ils vous embrasse plus
souvent votre jules
n'est pas vrai c'est
hélas dujardin est dit est ce qu'on peut
arrêter le tournage bien mais moi je
suis vraiment avec quelques mois c'était
une blague au début tu vraiment avec
avec son vin donc pu éviter quand même
parce que je suis marié encore
dans marie claire vous dites je n'ai
jamais attaqué un [ __ ] c'est mon ex
fiancé laurent gerra qui ont parlé
non mais non mais je vois quand même que
vous y tenez beaucoup parce que j'ai pas
lu merci depuis trois semaines sans que
vous y allez je veux me reprochez pas
d'en remettre une couche parce que vous
franchement décevant mais je suis pas là
pour ça ouais j'ai pas venu ici pour ça
c'est pour ça que vous avez quitté
laurent gerra je réponds pas je vis pour
l'éducation de rita
le problème c'est que moi une fois que
les gens étaient en face de moi je les
ai chié donc c'est difficile à
programmer les gens préfèrent aller
faire sucer brouckerque emmerdé par
ardisson et puis des fois joey starr
vous pétez un peu les plans
[Applaudissements]
alors vas pas faire le listing de tous
vos ennuis avec la justice mais
c'est vrai que j'avais eu souvent
l'occasion de vous affronter à vos
comptes en noir des jeux vous affrontez
une fois non ouais mais fait peur
j'arrive devant chez j'arrive devant
chez sony et puis je suis puisqu'elle
est dans l'entrevue que c'est sur elle
que je dirigeais à l'épaule a salué plus
qu'il y avait moi je sais ce qu'il
dirait moi j'étais avec avec mon amie
béatrice et pieux des gens nous ont été
tuées et puis dans l'entrevue j'ai vu
deux chars allemands ont été drogués un
truc un autre super anodin voire
carrément il y avait une page complète
ci n'ont pas ce complexe avec deux
lignes devraient dire qu'on était dans
la rue bien triche et moi je dis ce qui
était vrai le reste est à ce jour là si
je m'étais écoutez je vais jouer au
football avec lui je n'ai pas fait un
mec ce qui veut dire la vérité c'est un
mec est passé en bagnole qui a vu que
j'allais me faire assassiner sur place
vous qui m'a recueillie dans sa voiture
vous avez deux gros coups de pied dans
la dans la bagnole des portières étaient
en creux comme ça le mec s'arrêter 800
mètres plus loin j'ai dit je suis sorti
la boîte choisi voulu que je vous
rembourse pour la porte et invalidante
pas grave l'assurance paiera si vous
aviez ni dans ma tête il n'y aviez aimé
dans la bagnole je savoir pas pour pour
finaliser ça je suis venu donc c'est
voilà c'est fini maintenant ouais ouais
et l'hôtesse de l'air c'est elle qui
vous avez agressé aussi bah ouais mais
bon comme je dis toujours c'est sans
obligation d'achat qu'est ce qu'on en
veut plus à changer et vous aider à
mieux la cua de vous aider à mieux plus
calme c'est parce que vous avez un
disque à vendre parce que vous êtes fait
soigner
j'ai toujours vu comme un enfant mal
élevé qui se réjouissaient de tous ses
bons coups
il ya quelque chose qui moi n'est pas
dans ma nature mais voilà il je crois
qu'ils l'assument aussi il a un peu
c'est est quoi ils allaient gens qu'il
aime quoi qu'il arrive et puis ce qu'ils
n'aiment pas ou qu'ils détestent
également quoi qu'il arrive dans le rang
je te le dis je me suis engagé auprès de
orlando apprend par des dates hors de
nous on va le dire tout de suite qu'on
sent tellement gêné pas un renard
comme ça on l'a couché tout de suite et
maintenant on rentre dans les séries et
vous savez comment faire
c'est votre c'est votre septième report
apple a la poisse à sandrine
provient pas de quelqu'un
nadine de rothschild
elle venait pour des manuel de
savoir-vivre
et baffin jour lui a dit cette phrase la
basique alors nadine est ce qu'on peut
se soucier que sont pas
censés s'est trompé
qu'est ce que tu veux dire ah ça non
j'ai vu une exploser un bang big band se
réaliser 10 mg et pour le pire tu vas
voir les quinze ans maire de meaux je
mène une vie de moine agit pas de toi
j'ai mené mon fils et vous avez le droit
d'un jeu de maillots
ne sais pas du tout pour les en scope
lénifiants et je les dirai que l'envié
fois je suis pour dire les choses
quelque chose né le 18 on est né le 18
mai il avait essayé de m'en voulez pas
ce qu'on souhaitait de sa gueule parce
qu'on disait toujours qu'elle prédisait
rien de dieu c'était tout ce que je
prédisais n'allait pas
c'était très bizarre en fait c'est à
dire que les gens savent et je me fous
pas cela en tous les cas savais que
j'allais me [ __ ] de leur gueule mais
il venait quand même donc lé geneviève
et maintenant
ma tata yoyo bien sûr c'est drôle moi
j'adore tata yoyo c'est bien c'est
sympathique et tout annie cordy c'est
une boule de 2,2 de joie de détente et
tout bien sûr finalement y'a qu'ça
iliaque mon chapeau puis chapeau de tata
yoyo n'a pas 2 lors de la dernière
émission j'ai promis de m'habiller en
blanc si madame de fontenay a enlevé son
chapeau elle l'a fait je les fais on
regarde si vous enlevez votre chapeau
oui je vous promets que la prochaine
émission champs blancs mères
d'élever son turban je suis jeune homme
habillé en blanc querrey à cacher ça
grossit 56 un terrible blanc
le blanc ça grossit rassurez vous ça va
pas durer longtemps généré un jour j'en
ai fait un coup pour y ajoute des
chevaliers mais c'est une secte
dans ma pauv'dame on va voir man
histoire
[Musique]
s'était délitée
laetitia giry messi est jeune il va
puisque c'est comme ça puisque tu me
parles défaut smith deux mois je m'en
vais pas la peine que je reste alors je
m'en veux
[Applaudissements]
je prends l'eau
et là
je la suis je me mets à genoux
edit bon bah écoute tu te demande pardon
je ne crois pas je reviens alors je suis
revenue je ne recommande pas
geneviève je les aime beaucoup et
figurez-vous que on s'appelle très
régulièrement et si j'ai le malheur de
la laisser qu'un jour sans nouvelles
elle m'envoie un message m'a dit l'autre
en silence est assourdissant
moi je suis à tanger ne viendra pas
l'effectif n'est pas ma mère tous les
jours au téléphone
parfois il faut le dire je t'aime mais
je fais belles choses
oui on a une relation durable elle et
moi je sais pas si vous avez su comment
cet effet neutre en contre bas c'était
après une émission je retourne dans les
coulisses là bas dans les studios la
fille j'entends quelqu'un qui crie vous
n'avez pas vu passer une [ __ ] avec un
chapeau amazonie je vais devoir c'est y
remédie dont serait ta grand-mère d'une
à respecter les personnes âgées suite
ici alors il était resté complètement
figé s'attendait pas à ce que lui disent
ça et puis peu de temps après bas pour
revenir aux émissions avec ardisson dans
ma loge je voyais énorme au bouquet de
roses avec une carte geneviève je t'aime
en secret c'est maintenant voilà je
laime ces essais c'est venu comme ça
ouah
vous connaissez j'aime bien que
fortement lavage des dents et rachid
malienne mais voilà vous savez que si ma
dijonnais j'ai dit que j'ai trouvé un
petit mot gentil dans ma tête j'ai dit
vous savez j'aime bien que vous êtes un
personnage récurrent de cette émission
je ne pouvais pas faire moins que de
vous inviter je sais des gens fous c'est
tu as toujours des bonnes échanges
[Musique]
quand on arrive sur le plateau tout le
monde en parle on sait quand on rentre
on sait pas quand on va sortir le
tournage de tout le monde en parle et
très long c'était long à mourir je me
souviens d'avoir mal aux fesses d'avoir
le jean qui colle d'avoir chaud moi j'ai
le souvenir pendant un tournage d'avoir
fêté deux anniversaires c'est les
tournages les plus longs que j'ai vu de
ma vie on arrivait de labre on sortait
barbu il ya des moments ont piqué du nez
en furie littéralement ont piqué du nez
quand j'entends ça va plus ou moins oui
pourquoi pendant plus ou moins
normalement je suis endormi à 9h à
trélon pas en contenu obligatoirement
mais par ces petits breaks de dix
minutes un quart d'heure en fin de
soirée on pouvait commencer à 20h et
finir à 2 heures du mat d'armor
se recentrer en marche un peu et on va
s'occuper de monsieur mélenchon parfaite
[Musique]
c'est sûr que ça enlève de l'énergie
mais bon il est comme ça donc
voilà peut rien faire on passait d'une
émotion
à des rires à des invités différents
et la longueur on ne s'ennuyait pas
c'était comme une bonne soirée on va
chez des amis ont passé une soirée puis
à un moment donné on dit il est deux
heures du matin il faut qu'on rentre
qu'est-ce qu'il ya quelques semaines la
populace et vu non c'est bancal c'est
lui c'est faux que quelques bougies à
ton âge
[Applaudissements]
je reviens
après thierry choisissez ce qu'ils
avaient envie de choisir le fameux
montage ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
thierry
fait tout le montage donc il y était du
vendredi midi pratiquement au samedi
matin non-stop surtout pas l'appeler
aujourd'hui mon âge tu peux te fâcher à
ville
là il peut enlever le passeport double
la double nationalité soucis moi je
monte mes émissions parce que
je pense que je suis là pour donner aux
téléspectateurs
un beau produit donc au montage on coupe
concession les coupes qui était fait
dans tout le monde en parle et est
plutôt bienveillante on n'est pas là non
plus pour enfoncer les artistes
donc quelqu'un qui est comme ça ça se
passe mal pour humer bah oui oh oui y'a
pas de raison de montrer ça or après on
a commencé à dire oui mais ardisson il
fait du montage pour couper quand il est
mauvais donc à partir de là chaque fois
que je me plantais dans un lancement
dans un phase calmes que je faisais un
bug et tout je le laissais au montage
mais est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé à
votre enfant de rien dire à la mer à
propos de l'actrice dénudées qui étaient
là pour sa carrière en fait vous arriver
ça des référés
demandez à votre enfant de rien dire à
sa mère à propos de ces deux jeunes
actrices dénudées qui voulait juste des
oui non oui tout à fait non c'était un
mais en plus ils leurs pions parler
vraiment
la série oui je le darpa troisième fois
mais je serai toujours pas d'avoir des
bâtonnets de regrets mais
je n'aurai pas de bonnes mais je sais
même pas qui mais drôle bailly
est ce que vous allez demander
à propose sept jeunes actrices dénudées
qui voulait juste des conseils pour sa
carrière
il ya des interviews qui sont jamais
passées présentes le groupe zebda qui
est un groupe de toulouse ce qu'ils
racontaient je trouvais ça mais mes
chiens des pénibles mais nulle et toi et
donc j'arrive au montage lendemain matin
je dis bon vivre cette date les plans
larges tu peut pas virer un invité il
est dans les plans si vous vous démerdez
vous retail et dans l'image vous faites
ce que vous voulez je ne veux plus les
voir je me souviens même bien pourquoi
on les a coupés
mais après ça qu'alphonse et des
miracles au montage et on ne les a
jamais vus où on les voyait que sur
certains plans larges c'est donc le mec
de zebda il avait raconté à sa femme
qu'il était à paris pour faire tout le
monde en parle et quand l'émission est
passé le samedi j'imagine que sa femme
l'a dit mais qu'est ce tu me racontes
n'était pas du tout dans l'émission
d'ardisson quoi ils m'ont fait encore le
mec il en parle encore s'ils restent
évidemment dans l'équipe peut faire un
zelda c'est virer quelqu'un complètement
moi j'avais l'habitude de ne jamais
couper mes caméras donc y compris
c'est pour ça que par moments je
montrais ce qui se passe en coulisses on
gardait tout c'est à dire que en fait
dans l'émission regardez tout ce qui se
passait
[Applaudissements]
alexis crois que les mecs ils ont décidé
oui mais qu'est ce que ça va intéresser
le public mon spectacle ouais tu vas
voir qu'après cette émission son décor
il va intéresser le plus
[Applaudissements]
djamel selini chez
moi non mais non mais toi fais comme si
de rien et vous continuez vos émissions
allez-y
on y va
problème la caméra oui 4 je pense que ma
veste qu'il l'a pas fait nous pensons
joly revient il revient
elle tanit et l'oeil de freestyle c'est
le mail de blanc dit tu sais quand je
suis désolé c'est quitter le poste qui
sont avec toi là ddd il repris
[Rires]
et
bien sûr alors messieurs tu m'as
michal batory la [ __ ] dure donc avec
d'armand d'huîtres ans dany boon a
quand on va beaucoup s'amuser dany boon
tu vas tu l'as vu ces temps-ci non la
dernière fois que je les ai vus j'ai pas
de vue sa pièce mais
il était en vacances à megève
et s'est remise de sa séparation d'avec
guy dit parce qu'elle était lasse nadal
a l'air de s'être bien remis et je pense
à ces relations
il y avait dans l'émission toute une
toute une mise en abyme
que j'adorais c'est peut-être ce que je
regrette le plus jeune quand les gens
appeler on les prenait donc savez quand
je disais aux gens de laisser vos
programmes maintenant on dit aux gens
fermez vos portables et les cd portable
ouvert parce que c'est toujours marrant
[Musique]
l'eau est ce qu'il faut il sait il a une
opération c'est ça laurent tu peux pas
venir parce que tu as une opération très
grave non
[Applaudissements]
oui bah célinienne
ce que tu vas
à écoute moi je suis en vacances à poux
qui a caractérisé
on a fait de folies
si la musette et vivement qu'elle
construisait là mais oui
parce qu'on est obligé d'aller
constat qui se mobilisent
[Applaudissements]
dans les soumissions non mais
c'est pas acheter ce disque dans les
hôtels de passe de thaïlande
10 l'aubisque
le monde les banques françaises pour qui
la danse inquiète beaucoup les autres
s'inquiètent pour nous
car ici on prenait la
mission reprendre l'émission c'est que
vous regardiez notre caméra eye et
auxerre attention 3
tout le monde en parle c'était une
émission on avait une garantie de
liberté mon meilleur souvenir c'est
quand je tombe sur la carte cuts et moi
j'ai tout cela
et là je ne sais pas pourquoi je suis je
suis sortie de moi et je me suis dit
mais je vais dû péter la gueule
[Applaudissements]
on n'avait pas l'habitude de le voir
beaucoup de bois on avait l'impression
que tu es restée un peu un tronc
et je me suis mise à lui courir après je
crois qu'il a senti dans mes yeux je
rigolais pas donc il a eu peur
[Musique]
pourtant fort la pac
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est des prises de karaté je crois
que je vais enlever la sagesse le micro
est tombée
[Rires]
aujourd'hui il reste de tout le monde en
parle
l'idée l'idée de la déconne l'idée qu'on
pouvait faire n'importe quoi que qu'on
pouvait dire ce qu'on voulait que voilà
c'est la liberté la liberté un moment
avec michaël youn de quitter le plateau
d'aller sur le plateau d'à côté il y
avait julien lepers qui tournait
questions pour un champion moi je ferais
que c'était du bidon
avec plaisir c'est du placo ça ouais
ouais ça c'est des polystyrènes nicolas
je vois je demande à mon caméraman
devenir aussi j'ai toujours un cameraman
qui ne suis dans ma vie pour pâques
après ça n'est pas que tout ça c'est
laurence regarde bah oui c'est la
rédactrice en chef de l'émission on
embrasse sur la bouche dans la bouche
tout sinon nous allons
avec la langue et je mets les doigts
valérie maquilleuse non c'est c'est bien
parce que tous les deux on n'est pas
très grand et à la télé on fait plus
grands et là c'est que ces pratiques
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on fait
1,96 soul et de la gombe
merci l'ange blanc c'est ça la loge
blanc ça c'est mal je regarde regarde et
la culture vers 10 centimes alors
mesdames et messieurs c'est une avant
première pour la première fois la loge
de tirer ardisson ou lola
qu'est ce que tu fous là je te faisais
pas vrai avec des copines quand j'en
refais répéter le blind test voici
mobilib abordez vous le savez la
tradition ces démissions c'est qu'à la
fin de chaque émission il ya le blind
test présenté par
[Musique]
tout ce qu'il a sur les bras vont ils
avaient sur la barre
alors ça va les gars là
est marié et numérique vous aimez un
coup à un coût et que c'est une personne
telle mémoire
bon alors là on continue la visite tu
présentais un ami à moi ah je
connaissais pas du tout que j'ai
découvert qu'un mec vachement sympa mais
il a découvert normalement c'est que
j'ai découvert quand il est venu faire
l'émission ouais type extraordinaire
devait tenir lundi serait états pdc
qui devenait ministre le mec qui a écrit
une chanson très connue à chansons que
j'adore et tu mama on va le voir il
latvala s'est tout de suite mis travail
qui montrent que je me suis cependant
méfiant en effet un autre plateau
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ça me tape à paris j'avais fait plus
jamais possible
[Applaudissements]
miquel ouais
c'est bien de brooks hellzapoppin l'idée
d'aller sur le plateau voilà c'était
cette liberté là qui la chose à mon avis
la plus importante de l'émission
les corrections de ne rien rater de il a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus